from the company that owns a monopoly on
teenage girl fantasies comes the only
film about starving children with its
own delicious sandwich die in subway be
bold eat fresh
The Hunger Games Catching Fire you've
seen the first Hunger Games now prepare
for the way better follow-up to the
thinking girls Twilight and watch as
this good movie gets a load as great
because everyone wants to be BFFs with
Jennifer Lawrence I'm sorry I did a shot
before god she's just so down-to-earth
return to Panem where it's taken 75
years for people to get a little bit
upset about the annual child murdering
competition and reunite with Katniss
watch as this global role model and
feminist icon spends the entire movie
getting saved by boys duck
well get out of my way
complaining I don't want anyone looking
to me I'm really not in the mood for a
lecture so far I'm not overwhelmed by
our choices I should have just eaten
berries in the arena and died like I was
supposed to being antisocial these
tributes are crazy
God does anybody actually believe this
yes strangely dislike the person I've
never been very good at friends and
getting manipulated to the point where
her actions have no effect in the plot
at all you have been our mission from
the beginning better for you to know
nothing follow Katniss as she must once
again choose between Gale a total hunk
maker or Peeta a total burden to
everyone around him whether he's
drowning falling I can't carry him
wandering into a force field
or wandering into a pack of killer
monkeys nothing will stop PL his
never-ending quest to escape from the
friendzone watch your favorite color
I've stepped over the line seriously
though what is it yeah thank you
nobody needs me I need you
holy it worked not bad Cake Boss not bad
join Peeta and Katniss as they spend
twelve days riding around on a train you
never get off this train even though
flying hovercrafts exist in the same
movie then
gear up for Hunger Games all-stars
rumble in the jungle
full of new twists like older people
Falcor bees and the rotating danger
zones from Battle Royale meet new
competitors like Joanna a hottie who
does her best to make Katniss jealous
Finnick
a hottie who does his best to make
Katniss jealous and a bunch of new
random tributes who die before you even
bother to learn their silly names not a
threat so experienced a film that's
ultimately just a commercial for the
next film this is the revolution and
you're unlocking Jack which will
ultimately just be a commercial for the
next film because now every successful
franchise has to drag things out as long
as possible okay we'll go see the
sequels don't hurt us starring Jay Hajj
baby Thor Jack Bauer's dad Ryan Seacrest
minecraft Jeffrey wrong
Aqualad Yoda stormtroopers Matthew
McConaughey Jerry Bruckheimer films back
infinite arrows and a totally average
down-to-earth girl just like you
the Hunger Games Catching Fire now
that's how Buttercup is supposed to look
was that so hard guys thanks for
watching be sure to subscribe and tell
us in the comments below what movie you
want to see next I gonna kick ass and
child booboo gum where did you get those
clothes at the toilet store don't cross
the springs I'm the best there is at
what I do but what I do isn't very nice
the North retrievers I used to be an
adventurer like you then I took an arrow
in the knee